Hello Freak bitches.
We all know there's treatment,
different treatment,
right?
Celebrities,
well,
especially in Scientology,
right?
Yeah,
it's highlighted.
It is like nothing you could ever imagine.
It is.
So when people say Tom doesn't leave because they have information on him or
John,
that's not the reason.
The amount of power they receive from this church is like nothing in Hollywood.
It is like nothing.
There is no reason for them to leave this environment.
Right.
So it's super beneficial for them to be attached to it.
Correct.
He has employees,
they work for him.
All these people will take care of his every need.
Yes.
And there's a policy on how to talk to somebody.
Like you wouldn't say,
I'm like if you said go get me a go get me a coffee and I wanted this
temperature,
there's no,
I can't get it.
We're five miles from any,
you know,
with 30 there'll be none of that kind of talk.
Like not any con there's policy about don't you don't talk back like ever.
You don't step out of line.
You don't give an opinion.
You don't make a face.
You don't make a gesture.
You don't sigh if you step out of line in any way you are dealt with by the
Church essentially has servants.
Correct.
How many people?
A lot.
And by the way,
I don't begrudge somebody would have staff like if you can have it,
I go do it all day,
all night,
do it all day,
all night.
But when you believe as a scientologist,
you are working for somebody who single handedly is saving the planet and you
deserve that kind of punishment.
That's something different,
baby.
You understand what I'm like that,
that's,
it's an abuse that is not justified,
but it is justified because you believe that you are single handedly saving the
planet.
Hmm.
Capeesh yeah,
no,
I get it.
So,
um,
so he's the main figurehead,
right?
Right.
He's the main guy like right up with Miscavige.
And then John Travolta is somewhere in that,
I think John was given what a,
um,
a designation called [inaudible] where [inaudible] not,
can't con con.
Yeah.
Gacaca.
Okay.
He's given this designation of cocoon,
which there's a policy that basically says you can kill another human being.
If you were conned,
you're going to look the other way.
It was given that he was given that my l Ron Hubbard don't make me laugh cause
you gonna make me please don't make me repeat.
Don't let you out.
Sometimes you work on a car all those years.
First of all,
not very well.
Do you have any takes I ruined because of guys like Kevin Goes,
don't don't ruin this take.
I go,
no,
don't tell him you're going to do with that.
And then I would ruin it.
I would ruin a gel because he hit me.
He would do some stupid shit with his hands or something that he never rehearsed
that would make me cry from laughter.
Yes.
And he was really highly inappropriate and moments that made me Pete almost fee.
Yeah.
Okay.
So he's a lot of kill people.
Yeah.
Just one or are you getting,
I don't know.
I don't,
I should look at the policy again.
I don't want to us,
we get it.
But you're supposed to look the other way.
So like if somebody said something wrong to John Travolta Needs Polo,
Samurai sword and cut their head off,
you just got to clean up the body clean up called ethics protection.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So everyone would be responsible for dealing with it,
dealing with it.
Don't just leave the room.
And he would know that you guys would take care of it.
Correct.
And there's also another policy.
And by the way,
I,
the reason why I say these policies is because I don't like when people say,
Leah,
I believe you.
I don't want you to believe me.
I want you to look it up.
Right?
I want you to look for yourself and make your own decisions.
So I keep quoting these policies because I want people to look it up so that
they can say,
that's shit's true.
She's not talking shit.
You know what I mean?
Right.
There's another policy called ethics protection.
There's another policy called the responsibility,
the responsibility of leaders,
which he actually says exactly what you just said,
that,
uh,
basically,
you know,
the,
what you got to do to protect a leader,
you got to do it.
If you see a body,
then you clean it up and the leader should never know.